Turn on, tune in, drop out. This phrase was made famous by Harvard psychologist Timothy Leary, who in the 1960s was studying whether psychedelic drugs, particularly psilocybin and LSD, could have therapeutic uses. For a lot of reasons, including that he took the drugs along with his student subjects, Leary was fired from Harvard, and LSD, psilocybin, and other hallucinogenic drugs were deemed illegal by the Food and Drug Administration. Fast forward to 2020.
“开启、调频、脱离”（Turn on, tune in, drop out）。这句话因哈佛大学心理学家蒂莫西·利里（Timothy Leary）而闻名，他在20世纪60年代研究迷幻药物（特别是裸盖菇素和LSD）是否具有治疗用途。由于多种原因，包括他曾与学生受试者一起服用这些药物，利里被哈佛大学解雇，而LSD、裸盖菇素及其他致幻药物也被美国食品药品监督管理局（FDA）定为非法。时间快进到2020年。
Psychological research with hallucinogenic drugs is a legitimate field of study again, with the FDA allowing a handful of medical research organizations to conduct what's called breakthrough therapy with psychedelics. Researchers are looking at whether these drugs can be used to treat depression, anorexia, PTSD, and even alcohol and tobacco dependence. In June, advocates in Oregon announced they had gathered enough signatures to put an initiative on the state's November ballot that would legalize psilocybin-assisted therapy. Meanwhile, Washington, D.C. voters are likely to consider a psilocybin decriminalization measure this fall,
针对致幻药物的心理学研究再次成为一个合法的研究领域，FDA允许少数医疗研究机构对迷幻药进行所谓的“突破性疗法”研究。研究人员正在探讨这些药物是否可用于治疗抑郁症、厌食症、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），甚至是酒精和烟草依赖。今年6月，俄勒冈州的倡导者宣布他们已收集到足够的签名，将一项关于裸盖菇素辅助治疗合法化的倡议列入该州11月的选票。与此同时，华盛顿特区的选民今年秋天也可能会考虑一项裸盖菇素非刑事化措施，
following the examples of cities including Denver and Oakland and Santa Cruz, California, which have recently passed similar measures. So what's different about today's research using psychedelics? How do drugs that have long been considered taboo in polite society become tools for treating a growing number of mental health issues. We will be delving into these and other questions today here on Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life.
继丹佛、奥克兰和加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯等城市之后，这些城市最近都通过了类似的措施。那么，今天使用迷幻药的研究有什么不同之处？长期以来在文明社会中被视为禁忌的药物，是如何成为治疗日益增多的心理健康问题的工具的？今天，我们将在美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）中深入探讨这些及其他问题，该播客旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Roland Griffiths. He is Director of the Center for Psychedelic and Consciousness Research and a professor of psychiatry and behavioral sciences at Johns Hopkins University in Baltimore. The Center's Research Group was the first to obtain regulatory approval in the United States to reinitiate research with psychedelics in healthy volunteers. Their 2006 publication on the safety and enduring positive effects of a single dose of psilocybin is widely considered the landmark study that sparked a renewal of psychedelic research worldwide.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是罗兰·格里菲斯（Roland Griffiths）博士。他是巴尔的摩约翰霍普金斯大学迷幻药与意识研究中心主任，也是精神病学和行为科学教授。该中心的研究小组是美国第一个获得监管部门批准，在健康志愿者身上重启迷幻药研究的机构。他们2006年发表的关于单剂量裸盖菇素的安全性和持久积极影响的论文，被广泛认为是引发全球迷幻药研究复兴的里程碑式研究。
Dr. Griffiths himself has published widely on the psychological effects of sedative hypnotics, caffeine, and novel mood-altering drugs. In 1999, he initiated a research program investigating the effects of psilocybin in healthy volunteers, in long-term meditators, and in religious leaders. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Griffiths. Thank you, Kim. I'm pleased to be here. So my first question is, how did you get into this line of research?
格里菲斯博士本人在镇静催眠药、咖啡因和新型情绪调节药物的心理影响方面发表了大量文章。1999年，他启动了一项研究计划，调查裸盖菇素对健康志愿者、长期冥想者和宗教领袖的影响。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，格里菲斯博士。谢谢你，金。很高兴来到这里。那么我的第一个问题是，你是如何进入这个研究领域的？
Where were you in the 1960s and what were you doing? And on a more serious note, how were you able to do studies on psilocybin in 1999? So my training was in psychopharmacology, an interdisciplinary program in psychology and pharmacology. And I received my PhD at University of Minnesota and then came out to Johns Hopkins to pursue research on mood-altering drugs. And as you mentioned, I did quite a bit of research on sedative hematomics, caffeine, and a variety of other kinds of compounds. Most of our research was focused on drugs of abuse. And about 25 years ago, I started a meditation practice that got me very curious about the nature of altered states of consciousness and the potential for, transformative change. And in so doing, I became reacquainted with this older literature on psychedelics
你在20世纪60年代身在何处，在做什么？更严肃地说，你是如何在1999年进行裸盖菇素研究的？我的专业背景是精神药理学，这是一个心理学和药理学的跨学科项目。我在明尼苏达大学获得了博士学位，然后来到约翰霍普金斯大学从事情绪调节药物的研究。正如你提到的，我对镇静催眠药、咖啡因和各种其他化合物做了相当多的研究。我们的大部分研究都集中在滥用药物上。大约25年前，我开始练习冥想，这让我对意识改变状态的本质以及实现变革性改变的潜力产生了浓厚的兴趣。在此过程中，我重新接触到了关于迷幻药的旧文献，
that suggested that they might be useful tools for investigating the very states of consciousness that were really, I was finding so interesting through meditation. And it was that that got me interested enough to put in to our IRB and to FDA a protocol to investigate what turned out to be a high dose of psilocybin and comparing it to an active control compound methamphetade under deeply blinded, double-blind conditions. Two volunteers who were psychedelic, naive individuals. And in that sense, it was a study that had not been done for some decades after the shutdown of this research in the late 1960s, early 70s. So that was my lead in to this area. I was curious about states of consciousness. I had a personal sense of
这些文献表明，它们可能是研究意识状态的有用工具，而我通过冥想发现这些状态非常有趣。正是这一点让我产生了足够的兴趣，向我们的机构审查委员会（IRB）和FDA提交了一份方案，旨在研究高剂量的裸盖菇素，并将其与活性对照化合物甲哌卡因进行双盲对比。受试者是此前从未接触过迷幻药的志愿者。从这个意义上说，这是一项在20世纪60年代末、70年代初该领域研究被叫停后，几十年来从未进行过的研究。这就是我进入该领域的契机。我对意识状态感到好奇。我个人对
ambivalence about whether or not administration of psychedelics was going to lead to or fulfill the kinds of expectations that I saw promulgated by psychedelic enthusiasts at the time. Those seemed to me to be overzealous from my perspective. But indeed, the results of our initial study were nothing other than stunning to me. What we showed was that when psilocybin is given at a reasonably high dose to carefully prepared volunteers who have been very carefully screened and with whom we have spent significant time preparing them for a psychedelic session. When it's given to these people, they end up reporting having had experiences that are among the most personally meaningful and spiritually significant experiences of their entire
服用迷幻药是否会带来或实现我在当时迷幻药爱好者所宣传的那种期望感到矛盾。从我的角度来看，那些期望似乎过于狂热。但事实上，我们初步研究的结果让我感到震惊。我们发现，当向经过精心准备、严格筛选并花费大量时间为迷幻体验做好准备的志愿者提供合理高剂量的裸盖菇素时，他们最终报告说，这些经历是他们一生中最具个人意义和精神意义的体验之一。
lifetimes. And they may compare it, for instance, to the meaningfulness of the birth of a firstborn child or death of a parent. And more stunning than that was that the attributions that people made to these experiences endured over time. So months after the session, people would claim, would continue to claim that these were continuing to be the most meaningful experiences of their lives. And they made many positive attributions in terms of changes and moods, attitudes, and behavior to the experiences. So there's something really fundamentally interesting about these kinds of experiences that
他们可能会将其与第一个孩子出生或父母去世的意义相提并论。更令人震惊的是，人们对这些经历的归因随着时间的推移而持续存在。因此，在体验结束几个月后，人们仍然声称这些经历是他们一生中最有意义的时刻。他们将情绪、态度和行为方面的变化归功于这些经历。因此，这类经历中确实存在一些非常根本且有趣的东西，
for me as a scientist has just been riveting. to explore because so little research has been done for these, has been done on these compounds for some number of decades. So that sounds almost magical in a sense that this could happen, that a single dose could be so transformative for people. And I'm just wondering, how much do you know about what's happening in the brain that that may make this happen. Are you doing, for example, fMRI or PET scans during the course of the administration of these drugs?
作为一名科学家，这对我来说非常引人入胜，因为几十年来对这些化合物的研究实在太少了。所以这听起来几乎是神奇的，单剂量就能对人产生如此大的变革作用。我很好奇，你对大脑中发生的事情了解多少？例如，在服用这些药物的过程中，你是否在进行功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）或正电子发射断层扫描（PET）？
Yes, we are. And just to get to your point, it seems almost magical. It does seem unlikely, doesn't it? And I think that was one of the reasons, I think, that the scientific community, among others, and the psychiatric community was reluctant to even believe that these kinds of effects exist because we're unaccustomed to seeing abrupt changes in what amounts to personality and treat dispositional characteristics that occur so suddenly but can be done prospectively. So what in the world is going on here? How do we wrap our heads around this? How do we understand it? And the answer to that is complex and it's multi-level. So we know quite a bit about how these compounds were. But in a larger sense, we know very little. So let me just lead you through what we know and how we're trying to discover it.
是的，我们正在进行。回到你的观点，这看起来确实很神奇。这看起来不太可能，不是吗？我认为这也是科学界及精神病学界不愿相信这些影响存在的原因之一，因为我们不习惯看到人格和特质倾向发生如此突然的改变，但这些改变是可以前瞻性地实现的。那么，这到底是怎么回事？我们如何理解它？答案是复杂的，且是多层面的。我们对这些化合物的作用机制了解不少，但从更广泛的意义上讲，我们知之甚少。让我带你了解一下我们已知的内容以及我们试图探索的方向。
So psilocybin along with the other so-called classic psychedelics, which would include DMT, which is the active ingredient in ayahuasca and mescaline, which is the active ingredient in the peyote cactus and LSD, all of these classic psychedelics have their effect, their principal effect by binding the serotonin 2A receptor. And we know that from pre-clinical studies and from clinical studies in which we've given receptor blockers. So that initiates a cascade of activity. And we know that under acute administration of psilocybin, that there's vast network interconnectivity within the brain. There are areas of brain that are speaking with one another, if you will, that normally don't. And there's some organization to that. It's not just chaos. And signals of that sort have been demonstrated from MRI imaging studies that take a look at the brain function during acute.
裸盖菇素以及其他所谓的经典迷幻药（包括死藤水中的活性成分DMT、佩奥特仙人掌中的活性成分麦司卡林以及LSD），它们的主要作用是通过结合血清素2A受体来实现的。我们从临床前研究和给予受体阻滞剂的临床研究中得知这一点。这引发了一连串的活动。我们知道，在急性服用裸盖菇素的情况下，大脑内存在广泛的网络互联。大脑中某些区域在进行交流，而这些区域通常是不交流的。这并非混乱，而是有一定的组织性。MRI成像研究已经证明了这种信号，这些研究观察了急性服用
psilocybin or LSD administration. Once psilocybin is eliminated from the body, those brain circuits fall back into what appears to be a much more normal looking pattern. And so one of the questions then is what kind of enduring changes might occur in those brain systems. And we are doing before and after MRI studies and other imaging kinds of studies to try to get a sense of what kind of signaling is going on there. And we have some sense of that. One of the interesting observations that's been made with respect to brain function is that under acute administration of the psychedelics,
裸盖菇素或LSD期间的大脑功能。一旦裸盖菇素从体内排出，这些大脑回路就会恢复到看起来正常得多的模式。因此，问题之一是这些大脑系统中可能会发生什么样的持久变化。我们正在进行MRI前后对比研究和其他成像研究，试图了解那里发生了什么样的信号传导。我们对此有一些了解。关于大脑功能的一个有趣的观察是，在急性服用迷幻药的情况下，
there's a decreased functioning in something called the default mode network. Now, that's an interesting brain network that is usually online when people are told in the scanner don't do anything. And it's associated with mind wandering or self. self-referential behavior, also perseverative behavior of various types. And the default mode network function is increased in depression. It's decreased under psilocybin. And interestingly, it's decreased in long-term meditators. And so that fits with a story, if you will, of decreased in self-referential processing,
大脑中所谓的“默认模式网络”（Default Mode Network）的功能会降低。这是一个有趣的大脑网络，通常在人们被告知在扫描仪中“什么都不要做”时处于在线状态。它与思维游离或自我参照行为有关，也与各种类型的固执行为有关。默认模式网络的功能在抑郁症中会增强，而在服用裸盖菇素时会降低。有趣的是，它在长期冥想者中也会降低。因此，这与自我参照处理减少、
decreased egoic functioning, if you will. I'm sorry, egoic? I'm not familiar with that word. The egoic. Oh, gotcha, egoic. Well, yeah, to fall back on Freudian terminology, this sense of self and this self-referential inner discussion that we have falls away
自我功能（egoic functioning）减少的故事相吻合。抱歉，自我功能？我不熟悉这个词。自我功能。哦，明白了，自我功能。嗯，是的，回归弗洛伊德的术语，这种自我感和我们内心进行的自我参照讨论会消失，
and what emerges from that, and this is in the phenomenology of the psychedelic experience as well, is the present moment. So the past and the future drop away. One is very present with whatever is. And that's one of the qualitative features of these kinds of experiences. As well, people often report from a third. phenomenological point of view, something called a mystical type experience, which is this sense of a interconnectedness of all people and things, a unity, if you will, and that's often coupled with a
随之而来的是当下时刻，这也是迷幻体验现象学的一部分。因此，过去和未来都消失了。一个人非常专注于当下的任何事物。这是这类体验的定性特征之一。同样，人们经常从第三人称现象学的角度报告一种所谓的“神秘型体验”，即一种万物互联的感觉，一种统一感，这通常伴随着
sense of preciousness of that experience and the truth value of that experience. And that memory for that experience is what endures. So we're just beginning to explore the basic brain processes there. But then there's a, you know, you can approach this at the psychological level and say, well, how are people altered psychologically? And people make these positive attributions to these experiences in terms of their moods. Their moods tend to be better. They're less inclined to become upset.
对那种体验的珍视感以及对那种体验真实价值的认可。而对那种体验的记忆是持久的。所以我们才刚刚开始探索那里的基本大脑过程。但你也可以从心理层面来探讨，人们在心理上是如何改变的？人们将这些经历归功于他们的情绪改善。他们的情绪往往更好。他们不太容易变得心烦意乱。
They're more mindful. Their attitudes, they're more curious and engaged with life. They're more sensitive to other people and their behaviors. People are more likely if these are healthy volunteers to take on things, self-care activities like a better diet or change their exercise routine or engage in a more satisfying way with their loved ones. One of the constructs that we've been working with in terms of explaining how people are changed internally is that of psychological flexibility. It seems that these experiences for whatever reasons and through whatever mechanisms, be them basic brain functions or psychological,
他们更专注。在态度上，他们对生活更好奇、更投入。他们对他人的行为更敏感。如果是健康志愿者，他们更有可能采取自我保健活动，如改善饮食、改变锻炼习惯或以更令人满意的方式与亲人互动。在解释人们如何在内部发生改变方面，我们一直在研究的一个概念是“心理灵活性”。似乎这些经历，无论出于什么原因，通过什么机制（无论是基本大脑功能还是心理机制，
which of course blend at some point, that they result in an inclusive. increased psychological flexibility in which people seem to have more curiosity about the nature of mind. They're more able and willing to endure a discomfort. And they have an increased sense of self-efficacy. and I think it's that combination of things that people can that turn out to be therapeutically useful if we're studying things like the existential anxiety or distress attached to a life-threatening illness, major depressive disorder, or drug addictions. So what you are describing, the effects of this drug on people, just sounds wondrous, and not to be glib, but how do I get some?
当然，它们在某一点上是融合的），都会导致心理灵活性的增加，人们似乎对心灵的本质有了更多的好奇心。他们更有能力和意愿去忍受不适。他们有更强的自我效能感。我认为正是这种组合使得这些体验在研究诸如生命威胁性疾病带来的存在主义焦虑或痛苦、重度抑郁症或药物成瘾时具有治疗价值。所以你所描述的这种药物对人的影响听起来很奇妙，我不是想轻率，但我该如何获得一些呢？
I'm just wondering, do you think that this drug should be deregulated or more widely available? Because it sounds like it could help people in everyday life. Well, thank you for asking that. And the answer is that we need to be very cautious about this. The psychedelics have significant risks attached to them. And sometimes those risks get under-emphasized or de-emphasized by psychedelic enthusiasts. And it's something that we have been very interested and concerned about. We conducted a large-scale survey study in people who had used psilocybin in non-es.
我只是想知道，你认为这种药物应该取消管制或更广泛地使用吗？因为它听起来可以帮助人们的日常生活。嗯，谢谢你的提问。答案是我们对此需要非常谨慎。迷幻药伴随着巨大的风险。有时这些风险会被迷幻药爱好者低估或淡化。这是我们一直非常关注和担心的问题。我们对那些在非医疗环境下使用过裸盖菇素的人进行了一项大规模调查研究，
medical circumstances and ask them to tell us in great detail about their most challenging or difficult experiences and the consequences of those experiences. So this is not, the percentages of endorsement here don't represent the percentage from a first administration or single administration. These are people, for the most part, who had used psilocybin on any number of occasions and they were describing their very worst experience. But nonetheless, the results are really quite sobering. About 10% of those people endorsed having put themselves or others at risk for serious harm.
并要求他们详细描述他们最具挑战性或最困难的经历以及这些经历的后果。所以，这里的百分比并不代表首次服用或单次服用的比例。这些人大多曾多次使用过裸盖菇素，他们描述的是他们最糟糕的经历。但尽管如此，结果仍然相当令人清醒。大约10%的人承认曾使自己或他人处于严重伤害的风险中。
And so people can engage in, can become panicked or can confused and engage in dangerous behavior. And that could include running out into traffic or literally jumping out of a window or harming someone else in fear. But you said that's 10%. So what about the rest of the folks who answered this survey? Well, they didn't endorse that. So 90% didn't. But 10% is reasonably high.
所以人们可能会陷入恐慌或困惑，并做出危险行为。这可能包括冲向车流、从窗户跳下，或因恐惧而伤害他人。但你说那是10%。那么回答这项调查的其他人群呢？嗯，他们没有那样表示。所以90%的人没有。但10%的比例相当高。
Another 10% said that they had, they reported enduring psychological problems that lasted a year or longer after the experience. And that's certainly a concern. So panic is one, panic and confusion and engaging in dangerous behavior is one major concern. And the other major concern we have is that in vulnerable. population, so people who may have a predisposition to psychotic illness, the thought is that an experience of this sort might be enough to precipitate on-door enduring chronic illness. And it's for that reason that we, from all of our clinical studies, we exclude anyone with a personal or family history of schizophrenia.
另有10%的人报告说，在经历之后，他们出现了持续一年或更长时间的心理问题。这当然是一个令人担忧的问题。所以恐慌、困惑和危险行为是一个主要担忧。另一个主要担忧是，在弱势群体中，即那些可能有精神病倾向的人，人们认为这种经历可能足以诱发持续的慢性疾病。正是因为这个原因，在我们所有的临床研究中，我们排除了任何有精神分裂症个人或家族史的人。
And currently, we also exclude people with bipolar disorder if it has bipolar 1, which can have psychotic presentations. So there is concern about this. We are strong advocates, our research center, for systematic investigation of the risks and as well as the benefits and therapeutic efficacy of these compounds. And we think that that's best played out using the tools of science that we have through systematic research and ultimately regulatory trials that are currently ongoing. And there are two companies right now that are leading trials to investigate psilocybin as a treatment for either treatment-resistant depression or major depressive disorder. If those trials proceed and they're under the direction or under the control of FDA,
目前，我们也排除了患有双相情感障碍（如果是双相I型，可能会有精神病表现）的人。所以对此确实存在担忧。我们的研究中心强烈主张对这些化合物的风险以及益处和治疗功效进行系统性研究。我们认为，最好利用我们现有的科学工具，通过系统性研究和最终正在进行的监管试验来解决这个问题。目前有两家公司正在领导试验，研究裸盖菇素作为治疗难治性抑郁症或重度抑郁症的药物。如果这些试验进展顺利，并且在FDA的指导或控制下，
If those proceed and are positive, then we would expect within four to six years from now, psilocybin may be approved for medical use. And I'm thinking if it were, it's likely to be approved under very controlled conditions in which the drug is dispensed to clinics and providers who know how to manage these types of experiences and who can provide the screening and support during the sessions and the aftercare that is necessary to optimize experiences and minimize risks. So it would be kind of what you're doing right now where there would be people present at the time that somebody took the drug.
如果进展顺利且结果积极，那么我们预计在四到六年内，裸盖菇素可能会被批准用于医疗用途。我在想，如果获批，它很可能会在非常受控的条件下获批，药物会被分发到诊所和提供者手中，他们知道如何管理这些类型的体验，并能在疗程期间提供必要的筛查和支持，以及后续护理，以优化体验并最大限度地减少风险。所以这会和你现在做的事情类似，即在某人服用药物时会有专人在场。
Maybe you can talk about that and what the therapists do while they're sitting there because I would be concerned. I mean, it still would be possible, even though you're carefully screening your participants, for somebody to have what we from the 60s and 70s would call a bad trip. What happens then? Yes, well, let me describe the setup for the sessions, and then we can go into some of those more difficult experiences. So people are carefully screened.
也许你可以谈谈这一点，以及治疗师在旁边时会做什么，因为我会很担心。我的意思是，即使你仔细筛选了参与者，某人仍然可能经历我们60年代和70年代所说的“糟糕的旅程”（bad trip）。那时会发生什么？是的，好吧，让我描述一下疗程的设置，然后我们可以讨论一些更困难的经历。所以人们会经过仔细筛选。
We do psychological testing with them. We go through a full skid. We need to assure ourselves that we can develop a rapport and trust with them because these experiences at high doses of something like psilocybin can be very disorienting and people can feel really quite psychologically vulnerable. So we spend maybe eight. hours in contact time with them, and there are two therapists involved in this prior to the session. The psilocybin session itself involves people coming in, having had just a very light,
我们对他们进行心理测试。我们进行全面的结构化临床访谈（SCID）。我们需要确保我们能与他们建立融洽的关系和信任，因为在服用裸盖菇素等药物的高剂量下，这些经历可能会让人感到非常迷失方向，人们可能会感到心理上非常脆弱。所以我们可能会在疗程前与他们接触大约8个小时，并且有两名治疗师参与其中。裸盖菇素疗程本身包括人们进来，只吃了一顿非常清淡、
low-fat breakfast, taking a capsule that contains synthesized psilocybin. And then we had them lay on a couch for the day. The psilocybin effects last anywhere from six to seven hours. We had them lay on the couch with eyeshades and headphones through which they listen to a program of music. We ask people to direct their attention inward on their inner experience, And there are two therapists or guides present throughout the session day. And they're there to provide reassurance to the individual should they feel anxious or distressed. And so we're essentially creating this safe container for people to feel really quite vulnerable
低脂的早餐，服用一颗含有合成裸盖菇素的胶囊。然后我们让他们躺在沙发上一整天。裸盖菇素的效果持续六到七个小时。我们让他们戴上眼罩和耳机，通过耳机听一段音乐节目。我们要求人们将注意力转向内心，关注他们的内在体验。在整个疗程期间，有两名治疗师或向导在场。如果个人感到焦虑或痛苦，他们会在那里提供安慰。所以我们本质上是在为人们创造一个安全的容器，让他们感到非常脆弱，
and explore the inner workings of their mind, if you will. The invitation is, now this is not, so it's not a guided session per se. We're not trying to ask, asking people to go any place in particular. What we're doing is asking people just to be with whatever it is that they're experiencing. Now, very often and very commonly there'll be visuals. Images may appear or patterns may appear, but that does, it's not true of everybody, but for many people. Emotions may vary widely from, as I described, kind of transcendent and, and, open-hearted to experiences of really great anxiety or fear and anything in between.
并探索他们心灵的内在运作。邀请是——这不是一个指导性的疗程本身。我们不是试图要求人们去任何特定的地方。我们所做的是要求人们只是与他们正在经历的任何事物在一起。现在，通常会有视觉效果。图像可能会出现，或者图案可能会出现，但这并不适用于所有人，但对许多人来说是这样。情绪可能会有很大差异，正如我所描述的，从那种超越和心胸开阔，到经历极大的焦虑或恐惧，以及介于两者之间的任何情绪。
People that on these high doses are really often incapable of navigating around the world in any normal circumstance. These are very high doses of Silsaimid. We check in with the volunteers throughout the session and if they're experiencing significant anxiety or fear will provide reassurance to them. We may take their hand, tell them they're doing just fine, that there's reassure them that there's nothing in the experience that can harm them. And what we invite them to be is curious and interested in the nature of the experience.
在这些高剂量下，人们通常无法在任何正常情况下在周围环境中活动。这些是极高剂量的裸盖菇素。我们在整个疗程中会与志愿者核对，如果他们感到明显的焦虑或恐惧，我们会为他们提供安慰。我们可能会握住他们的手，告诉他们做得很好，并向他们保证体验中没有任何东西会伤害他们。我们邀请他们对体验的本质保持好奇和兴趣。
And that's one of the profound teachings that come out of these experiences, and that is that the mind is a remarkable playground of objects that emerge, thoughts that emerge in mind, images that may emerge in mind. But that's just it. It's a play of consciousness. And if one can recognize that, even if what is emerging is fearful imagery or fearful thoughts, then one comes out with just a renewed sense of control and ability to tolerate and be interested and curious with whatever it is that emerges in mind. be it pleasant or unpleasant. And I think therein lays part of the power of the psychological flexibility, because if one comes out of an experience having faced their demon, if you will, and that could be literally or figuratively, you know, a vision of a demonic figure that's about to destroy them,
这是这些经历带来的深刻教导之一，那就是心灵是一个非凡的物体游乐场，思想在心灵中浮现，图像在心灵中浮现。但就是这样。这是一种意识的游戏。如果一个人能认识到这一点，即使浮现的是恐惧的意象或恐惧的思想，那么一个人出来时也会有一种更新的控制感，以及忍受、感兴趣并对心灵中浮现的任何事物保持好奇的能力，无论是愉快的还是不愉快的。我认为心理灵活性的力量部分就在于此，因为如果一个人在面对他们的“恶魔”后走出体验，无论是字面上的还是比喻上的，你知道，一个即将摧毁他们的恶魔形象，
But it may as well come in the form of feeling that they're dying or the feeling that they've gone insane and they're never going to get back to consensual reality. These difficult experiences can take any form and shape and they'll be unique to the individual. But if one can experience that and stay with it and see it for what. it is, and that is that it's simply a temporary illusion of consciousness, then one comes out of those experiences and is able to engage in normal everyday life and the difficulties one normally faces in life and recognize the extent to which they're wrapping their own thoughts around and they're becoming their own worst enemy in how they're holding their experiences. of life. And therein, I think, lies the power of this psychological flexibility.
但也可能表现为感觉自己快要死了，或者感觉自己疯了，再也回不到共识现实中。这些困难的经历可以采取任何形式和形状，并且对个人来说是独特的。但如果一个人能经历这些并坚持下去，并看清它的本质，即它仅仅是意识的一种暂时幻觉，那么一个人就会从这些经历中走出来，并能够参与正常的日常生活以及生活中通常面临的困难，并认识到他们在多大程度上束缚了自己的思想，以及他们在如何看待生活经历时成为了自己最大的敌人。我认为，心理灵活性的力量就在于此。
So some of the people you have worked with are terminal cancer patients, right? And I think what I've read is some of them kind of confront the idea of death. And then when they come back from having taken the drug, they are less fearful and are able to live what's left of their lives in a very mystical state almost. Yes, so the first clinical population that we worked with were individuals who had life-threatening cancer diagnosis and had significant anxiety and depression. And we thought this, you know,
所以你合作过的一些人是晚期癌症患者，对吧？我想我读到过，他们中的一些人会面对死亡的概念。然后当他们从服用药物中回来时，他们不再那么恐惧，并能够以一种几乎神秘的状态度过余生。是的，所以我们合作的第一个临床群体是那些被诊断出患有危及生命的癌症并伴有严重焦虑和抑郁的个体。我们认为这，你知道，
Stirling was among the most difficult existential dilemmas that we as sentient human order. organisms can face. And the remarkable thing about that was that people had these experiences, sometimes of a spiritual nature, but not always. But there was a larger framing that came out. Now, some people would make the claim that their experience. reassured them that
这种挣扎是我们作为有感知的人类有机体所能面临的最困难的存在主义困境之一。令人惊奇的是，人们有了这些经历，有时是精神层面的，但并不总是。但出现了一个更大的框架。现在，有些人会声称他们的经历
that death was just an illusion. And of course, we have lots of religious traditions that teach just that. But that wouldn't, that's not a necessary outcome. There's another way of holding these experiences. And so the precise interpret, the precise interpret, of this is going to vary, and I think it's going to vary depending on the culture of the person and some kind of pre-existing, you know, ideas or dispositions. So kind of if you believe in an afterlife, you may experience that sense? Yes. And some people go in, not believing in an afterlife, but come out believing in the possibility of an afterlife.
向他们保证死亡只是一个幻觉。当然，我们有很多宗教传统正是这样教导的。但这并不是一个必然的结果。还有另一种看待这些经历的方式。因此，对此的精确解释将会不同，我认为这取决于个人的文化以及某种预先存在的想法或倾向。所以，如果你相信来世，你可能会体验到那种感觉？是的。有些人进去时不相信来世，但出来时相信来世的可能性。
But, you know, other people would say what they really appreciate is just the larger mystery of what we don't understand about this whole project of what it is to be a conscious human being, that there's an elegance to being a sentient human being. There's a connectedness to this project of consciousness that's all our. around us and into which we're sensitive, that is so marvelous and so inscrutable that there's something absolutely beautiful about this play of life. And so people are much more content to just live their lives and they recognize
但是，你知道，其他人会说他们真正欣赏的只是我们对作为一个有意识的人类这一整个项目所不了解的更大的奥秘，即作为一个有感知的人类有一种优雅。这种意识项目有一种连通性，它就在我们周围，我们对此很敏感，它是如此奇妙且不可捉摸，以至于这种生命的游戏中存在着绝对美丽的东西。所以人们更满足于只是过他们的生活，他们认识到
everyone is gonna die at some point. And so the end, Anxiety somehow just for many people just drops away and they're able to live their life more fully, whether or not they believe in an afterlife. I should say that one of the things that we're seeing across these studies, though, is this altered sense of what we believe reality. to be made up of. It's a much larger project than many people have here to have contemplated prior to going into these sessions. It's simply much more, it's much larger and more mysterious.
每个人最终都会死。所以焦虑在某种程度上对许多人来说就消失了，他们能够更充分地生活，无论他们是否相信来世。我应该说，我们在这些研究中看到的一件事是，这种对我们认为现实是由什么组成的改变了的看法。这比许多人在进入这些疗程之前所考虑的项目要大得多。它只是更宏大、更神秘。
And there's a sense of humbling that comes out of having that experience, really a sense of astonishment at the time. the largeness of the project, in a sense of gratitude that comes out for being gifted this opportunity to be this sentient, highly evolved human creature walking the face of the earth, who, and we find ourselves with this astonishing fact that we are aware that we're aware. And it's really so puzzling. But it's the very nature of what it is to be a conscious human entity. And there's grandeur and beauty and humility that comes out of that. So you alluded to using hallucinogens to overcome alcohol addiction. I'm just wondering, that sounds almost counterintuitive that a drug
拥有这种经历会带来一种谦卑感，在当时确实有一种惊奇感，感受到这个项目的宏大，以及一种感激之情，感谢被赋予这个机会，成为这个行走在地球表面的、有感知、高度进化的生物，我们发现自己拥有一个惊人的事实，即我们意识到我们是有意识的。这真的很令人困惑。但这正是作为一个有意识的人类实体的本质。从中产生了一种宏伟、美丽和谦卑。所以你提到了使用致幻剂来克服酒精成瘾。我只是想知道，这听起来几乎是反直觉的，一种药物
that makes you in some sense feel, if not high, at least ecstatic. How could that be effective to help someone who's got a substance use disorder who's probably using the substance to feel some kind of, if not euphoria, at least to feel somehow better? How does that work? Yeah, well, one point I'd make right off the top is that the classic psychedelics are not considered drugs of addiction. The National Institute on Drug Abuse does not classify them as drugs of addiction or dependence.
在某种意义上让你感到，如果不是兴奋，至少是狂喜。对于一个可能有物质使用障碍的人来说，这怎么能有效呢？他们可能正在使用这种物质来获得某种感觉，如果不是欣快感，至少是感觉好一点？这是如何运作的？是的，好吧，我首先要指出的一点是，经典迷幻药不被认为是成瘾药物。美国国家药物滥用研究所（NIDA）不将其归类为成瘾或依赖药物。
They're not self-administered by laboratory animals. Why, they may produce positive states of consciousness, they also produce very negative states of consciousness. As a matter of fact, the Addiction Research Center in Lexington, Kentucky, that developed a lot of original. measures of subjective effects of drugs had something called the LSD scale. And that scale, that was a rating scale people completed, that scale was thought to be a prototypic scale to measure dysphoria or unpleasant effects of drugs. So these certainly don't routinely produce positive effects. And I should say I didn't mention about 30% of people undergoing our trials, which are optimized for producing positive changes.
它们不会被实验动物自我给药。虽然它们可能会产生积极的意识状态，但它们也会产生非常消极的意识状态。事实上，位于肯塔基州列克星敦的成瘾研究中心开发了许多原始的药物主观效应测量方法，其中有一种叫做“LSD量表”。那个量表，即人们完成的评定量表，被认为是衡量药物烦躁或不愉快影响的原型量表。所以这些药物肯定不会常规产生积极影响。我应该说，我没有提到大约30%参加我们试验的人（这些试验旨在产生积极变化），
About 30% will report having had a deeply fearful experience at some point during that session. It may be of short duration or longer duration. But that aspect of the experience is not escapable. But you ask a good question. So why would these be useful for drug addiction? So when we initiated our first study in the addictions, we actually chose tobacco dependence. And these are studies that have been done by Matt Johnson in our group. And we thought we didn't want to start out with cocaine or alcohol or opiate dependence because we didn't know what was going to happen.
大约30%的人会报告在疗程中的某个时刻有过深刻的恐惧经历。它可能是持续时间短或持续时间长。但体验的那个方面是无法逃避的。但你问了一个好问题。那么为什么这些对药物成瘾有用呢？当我们启动第一项成瘾研究时，我们实际上选择了烟草依赖。这些研究是由我们小组的马特·约翰逊（Matt Johnson）完成的。我们认为我们不想从可卡因、酒精或阿片类药物依赖开始，因为我们不知道会发生什么。
We didn't know if these were going to have positive effects. And we ran initially a small pilot study in 15 chronic cigarette smokers and combined psilocybin administration with cognitive behavior therapy for. cigarette smoking cessation. And the results showed that 80% of that group was abstinent, biologically verified abstinence at six months. Now that's actually an outrageous, outrageous outcome for cigarette smoking. Because it's so high. It's so high. It's just, It's unthinkably high. And so we now are proceeding, Matt's running comparative efficacy study, comparing a psilocybin intervention with nicotine replacement.
我们不知道这些是否会有积极的影响。我们最初在15名慢性吸烟者中进行了一项小型试点研究，并将裸盖菇素给药与戒烟的认知行为疗法相结合。结果显示，该组中有80%的人在六个月时戒烟，并经过生物学验证。这对于戒烟来说是一个令人震惊的结果。因为比例太高了。太高了。这高得不可思议。所以我们现在正在进行，马特正在进行比较疗效研究，将裸盖菇素干预与尼古丁替代疗法进行比较。
But other investigators, Michael Bogun shoots at New York University, is doing very promising work in alcoholics. And he's seen a very positive signal there. and Peter Hendricks down at University of Alabama and Birmingham is showing a positive signal with cocaine in his preliminary studies, and we're about to launch a study in opiate users. So it does appear, and this is one of the remarkable features of the psychedelic. as therapeutics, it does appear that they have cross or transdiagnostic efficacy, that they act across a range of different conditions.
但其他研究人员，如纽约大学的迈克尔·博根舒茨（Michael Bogenschutz），在酗酒者身上做了非常有希望的工作。他在那里看到了一个非常积极的信号。伯明翰阿拉巴马大学的彼得·亨德里克斯（Peter Hendricks）在他的初步研究中显示了可卡因的积极信号，我们即将启动一项针对阿片类药物使用者的研究。所以，作为治疗手段，迷幻药的一个显著特征似乎是它们具有跨诊断的功效，即它们在多种不同条件下都能发挥作用。
So, you know, we're accustomed to treating drug dependence with a pharmacological tool that's specific for the receptor and the drug for which people are dependent on. Like methadone for heroin addiction. Correct. And nicotine replacement for cigarettes. Yeah. Right, right. But here we have this intervention that appears to be efficacious across a range of drugs.
所以，你知道，我们习惯于用一种针对受体和人们所依赖药物的药理学工具来治疗药物依赖。比如美沙酮治疗海洛因成瘾。没错。还有尼古丁替代疗法治疗香烟。是的。没错。但在这里，我们有这种干预措施，似乎在多种药物中都有效。
And again, it's pointing toward this psychological flexibility as being the mediator. of this, you know, rather than interacting at a specific receptor site system that's underlying the addiction process of that, of the particular problematic drug. So just a last question. We may have listeners who are experiencing depression, substance use disorders, or other mental health problems, who think that this kind of therapy sounds like something they would like to participate in? How do they get involved? And if not, at Johns Hopkins, where can they apply to become participants in tests and trials? Yes. So as I mentioned, there are two entities that
同样，它指向心理灵活性作为这一过程的调节者，而不是与特定药物成瘾过程底层的特定受体位点系统相互作用。所以最后一个问题。我们可能有听众正在经历抑郁症、物质使用障碍或其他心理健康问题，他们认为这种疗法听起来像是他们想要参与的？他们如何参与？如果不是在约翰霍普金斯大学，他们可以在哪里申请成为测试和试验的参与者？是的。正如我提到的，有两家实体
are running clinical trials right now, except for all research centers being shut down, at least temporarily that those trials will continue. And that's the USONA Research Institute and Compass Pathways. And if people Google those, you can find them online, you can enroll in their trials. Both of those companies have a series of sites across the country that are enrolling volunteers, were enrolling volunteers for the USONA trial at Johns Hopkins in Baltimore, but there, I think there are about 10 sites across the country for each of those entities. And so people could apply for those studies.
目前正在进行临床试验，除了所有研究中心暂时关闭外，至少那些试验会继续进行。那就是USONA研究所（USONA Research Institute）和Compass Pathways公司。如果人们在谷歌上搜索这些，你可以在网上找到它们，你可以报名参加他们的试验。这两家公司在全国都有多个站点招募志愿者，我们在巴尔的摩的约翰霍普金斯大学为USONA试验招募志愿者，但我认为每家实体在全国大约有10个站点。所以人们可以申请这些研究。
That said, you know, the inclusion, exclusion criteria are substantial, and people may get randomized to a placebo or an in-fet or a very low-dose condition. But that's the nature of what's required in order to run regulatory trials. Sure. Great. Well, Dr. Griffith, thank you so much for joining us today. This conversation has been enlightening on many, many levels. Let me just add that your listeners could also look up our center website.
话虽如此，你知道，纳入和排除标准是相当严格的，人们可能会被随机分配到安慰剂组、活性对照组或极低剂量组。但这就是进行监管试验所必需的性质。当然。太好了。好吧，格里菲斯博士，非常感谢你今天加入我们。这次谈话在许多层面上都令人大开眼界。让我补充一点，你的听众也可以查看我们中心的网站。
If you Google Hopkins Psychedelic, you'll find the center, the Johns Hopkins Center for Psychedelics and Consciousness Research. And we're running a number of studies through our center and some of which we're recruiting from out of state. So if you look at the studies that we're recruiting for and those are consistent with a medical condition you have or interests that you have, you should feel free to complete the online screeners. Great. We can add some of that information to the program notes that we'll put on our website. Okay, Greg. Great.
如果你在谷歌上搜索“Hopkins Psychedelic”，你会找到该中心，即约翰霍普金斯迷幻药与意识研究中心。我们正在通过我们的中心进行多项研究，其中一些我们正在从州外招募。所以如果你查看我们正在招募的研究，并且这些研究与你患有的医疗状况或你的兴趣相符，你应该随时完成在线筛选。太好了。我们可以将其中一些信息添加到我们将放在网站上的节目说明中。好的，格雷格。太好了。
Thank you. For our listeners who want to learn even more about the use of psychedelics and psychotherapy, you can also read the cover story in the March 2020 issue of the Monitor on Psychology, the magazine of the American Psychological Association. You can find it on our website at APA.org slash monitor. If you have comments or ideas to share about our podcast, send us an email at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology all one word.org. Please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. It really helps. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple,
谢谢。对于想要进一步了解迷幻药和心理治疗使用的听众，你还可以阅读2020年3月刊《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）的封面故事，这是美国心理学会的杂志。你可以在我们的网站APA.org/monitor上找到它。如果你有关于我们播客的评论或想法要分享，请发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是speakingofpsychology，所有单词连在一起，点org。请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。这真的很有帮助。你可以在Apple上找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目，
Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website and get all episodes at www. www. speakingof psychology.org. Thank you for listening. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Stitcher、Spotify或任何您收听播客的地方。您也可以访问我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org获取所有剧集。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。